JASON CRANE: Good
afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to Zagat
Guest Chefs at Google.
My name is Jason Crane, and
I'm a chef here on campus,
and it is my proud pleasure to
welcome Marcy Masumoto today
from Masumoto Family Farms
in Del Rey, California.
They are a local family-owned
peach grower and farmer,
and they also do
nectarines, and raisins,
and some other
interesting things too.
And we'll get to
talking about that,
but I'd like to start off
by just letting Marcy talk
a little bit about what goes
on out there in her own words
and maybe do a little
reading from the book.
And then we'll get to the Q&A.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Absolutely.
Thank you.
It's my pleasure to be here.
What a delight to
be on this campus
and enjoying the world
through the view of Google.
I love it anyhow.
My pleasure.
So my name is Marcy Masumoto.
I am part of the
Masumoto Family Farm.
My husband's grandfather-- all
his grandparents immigrated
from Japan turn of the century,
a hundred and something years
ago, and settled in the
Central Valley near Fresno.
World War II came around.
Japanese-Americans were
relocated to relocation camps,
and my husband's father chose
to return to the Central Valley
to farm.
And it wasn't until 1948
then, after World War II,
that the family actually
had enough money
to purchase the land themselves.
And we actually
live on that farm
that the family bought
so many years ago.
Since then, about
20 years later,
they purchased an
adjacent 40 acres.
So at this point
the Masumoto family
owns-- we are a
small farm, and we
have an 80-acre farm,
family-run and operated.
We live on this farm.
My kids grew up on the farm.
So my daughter's taking
over the farm now.
She's 28 years old and
had made the decision
while she was in
college that she
wanted to come back to the farm.
She realized that this was her
life, this was her passion,
and you could see a
picture of Nikiko there.
But she's taking over
the farm, and so she
will be the fourth
generation working the land.
We grow grapes and
peaches, about 25 acres
of the tree fruit.
We have seven
different varieties
of peaches, three
varieties of nectarines.
And then the balance of our land
is two things at this point.
We grow Thompson seedless
grapes for raisins,
and then we also have some land
that we're giving a rest right
now, especially with the
drought and the lack of water.
We've for a couple years now, we
are fallowing some of the land
and returning it to some natural
landscape, which is certainly
beneficial for an organic farm.
So that's a little bit about
the history of our farm.
The book that we're
celebrating today
was a joint effort
between the three
of us, my daughter, my
husband, and myself.
It came out just last June.
It's called "The Perfect
Peach-- Recipes and Stories
from the Masumoto Family Farm."
Probably a little
bit that I should add
is that books are not
new to our family.
This was the first book that
my daughter and I were involved
with writing, but my
husband's also a writer,
so he's published
a number of books.
Maybe some of you have
heard of some of them.
But his first book that was
published here in the US
was "Epitaph for
a Peach," and that
was a literary piece about
saving the family farm.
And that book, years
ago, was honored
as a Julia Child Cookbook Award
winner in the literary food
category.
No recipes in that book.
My husband does not cook.
My daughter and I are
the cooks, and so we
did the other part of this
book, so it's a combination.
So that's kind of a
little bit about us.
Let me just share just a
tiny bit about this book
and what it is that we're
here to talk today about.
The book we called, "The
Perfect Peach," because I think,
for those of you that
enjoy fruit, you're
always in search of that
elusive, perfect fruit.
Whether they're in season, out
season, you're at the store,
you're at home.
If you have a memory of
a great-tasting peach,
you're always in search of
that great-tasting peach.
So let me just read
just a short passage
from the beginning
of the book, and this
is a passage my
daughter wrote called,
"Learn to Love a Peach."
We are in love with peaches.
This peach love and,
consequently, this book
is not really about
perfection, or rather it is,
but it's a different
kind of perfect.
A perfect dressed in
hand-me-down clothes
that passed from
generation to generation.
Maybe there's no
pre-existing perfect peach.
Instead, maybe a
peach becomes perfect
when it reminds us of
the deep connections that
are already present
when we eat one.
Maybe a perfect
peach wakes us up
through our senses to listen,
appreciate, and champion
the ways in which we are
interdependent as farmers,
workers, cooks, and eaters.
This is perfection in
process that I see.
So that gives you a little
flavor of this book.
JASON CRANE: Great.
That was a nice reading.
So to just get into our Q&A,
the title of the book is called,
"The Perfect Peach."
Can you break that down and talk
about what that really means?
And I think you started a
little bit with your reading
right there, but just
elaborate a little bit
on what that means to
you and your family.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Exactly.
So to us, the perfect
peach is not just
that little round ball
of flesh, but it's also
about the story, and the
history, and the place
that it came from.
And so for us, as
family farmers,
we feel it is really
important that we
try to connect our fruit and our
place with those that enjoy it.
So the perfect peach
is maybe, in a way,
part of your imagination.
But in another way,
I think something
that we seek to enjoy.
And part of our effort
here is not only
sharing the story
about the family
and the farm and the
practices, but then
how can each of us
use these peaches
other than just
eating out of hand?
The fact that we love
peaches, we're home cooks,
we're not trained chefs,
but we're home cooks,
and we love peaches, and we
have certainly a large supply
of peaches.
And if you have
access to good fruit,
whether it's in your
neighbor's backyard,
or you have a favorite
farmer at a farmer's market
that you enjoy
picking up your fruit,
we would like to
have you celebrate
that fruit in
every type of dish,
as well as year-round if
you have that opportunity.
JASON CRANE: Excellent.
So you brought this up a little
earlier with your husband's
first book, and in part of
the beginning of that book,
you talk about this being
a literary cookbook.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Right.
JASON CRANE: You want to
explain a little bit about what
you mean by this being
a literary cookbook?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
Some of our people
that we've come across
have said that they've
actually taken their cookbook
to bed with them
at night and read
a chapter or so
before falling asleep.
And the whole idea of the
literary cookbook, it's
not just a collection
of recipes.
It's more than that.
It's the stories-- the backstory
of not only the recipe itself,
which each have
headnotes explaining,
where did the inspiration
come from this recipe?
Or is it a family recipe?
But also tying together
through a narrative,
the story about the farm.
If I could share a little
bit about even the table
of contents and the chapters.
So we started with
a peach primer
wanting to share with
others what we've
learned over the years
of raising peaches.
So what is it about peaches?
How do you pick a
Peach when is it ripe?
What are the varieties?
That kind of thing.
But then there's
the next chapter
is about thirst and sweat.
are This is a chapter
about beverages and stories
about work.
And that life on the
farm is not just bucolic,
and that romantic image
that some people have,
it's a lot of work.
And so what goes
along with work?
Well, it's sweat.
And how do you
quench that sweat?
It's with beverages.
So we've got a great selection
of beverages there too.
Then we've got a
chapter, At the Table,
which includes savory dishes and
stories about family farming.
So we've got a great
variety of savories.
You can't have peach
recipes and peach stories
without Sweet Dreams, or sweets.
So this is a section about
sweet dishes and peach pleasure,
so we love the metaphor
of peaches and love.
And then finally,
Harvest Memories
is the last section, in which
we include stories about legacy,
but also recipes
about preserves.
How do you enjoy that peach
if it's got a short season?
How do you enjoy that
the rest of the year?
And part of our goal there
was to share with others
the simple truth
about how to preserve
your food, whether it's
freezing or canning, or drying.
So it was kind of a little
narrative through the book.
JASON CRANE: Yeah, it
was an interesting read.
I haven't finished it yet,
but looking through it,
getting prepared for
this, it was interesting
being able to see the stories,
and how the book went along,
and how the recipes matched and
went along with the stories,
and it wasn't just
an encyclopedia
of how you could use a
peach every way possible.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Exactly.
It's not everything
that is known
in the world about peaches.
It's not an
encyclopedia-type book,
but it's through the eyes of
the growers, and the eaters,
and the home cook.
And I think one of the fun
elements about the book
is the photography, also,
that we purposefully
had the photographer taking
images not only of the dishes,
but also of the farm and
what was going on on the farm
throughout the year.
So we have some
images-- I'm just,
I should have that
one labeled here--
but images even of thinning
peaches and harvesting,
images during the wintertime
when the trees are dormant,
and they're resting.
And I would like to
think that they're
images that also help
educate our readers
and our eaters of what
is happening on the farm
year-round.
JASON CRANE: It's not
really a question,
but just to follow up on that.
You talk in there a little
bit of having agenda
to try to get everyone
to love peaches,
and I think what we just
talked about right there
and what you were
saying goes along
those lines of being
your agenda of this book.
To get people to understand
the life of the peach
and everything that
goes into the farming,
from your family
to your workers,
to everything that
goes into bringing
these wonderful
peaches to market.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Exactly.
That it's both a
labor of labor of love
as well as pure labor that
goes into producing peaches.
We happen to be a
certified organic farm,
and so our practices
are-- we strive
to be sustainable to raise
fruit that's environmentally
correct, that's not damaging
the earth, that's profitable,
because if it's not
profitable, we're not
going to be in business, and
that's also socially just.
And part of that
is how do we deal
with our workers
and our laborers?
And those are real issues.
What are the
immigration policies,
and how do those impact the
food that we eat every day?
So it's more than just a peach.
JASON CRANE: Well, while
we're talking about organics,
can you talk a
little bit about what
it takes to be an organic farm?
And since you guys have
been an organic farm
since the '80s, a little
bit of the differences
that go into what it was back
then to what it entails now.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
Well, when we
transitioned to organic
we were kind of
in the early wave.
There were few people
doing organics,
and those that were
definitely on the fringes.
So in the early years, we
were developing the methods.
Of course, generations
ago, almost all farming
was organic, but then through
the industrial era, everything
switched over to what we now
call conventional farming,
where it was common
practice to be
using pesticides and herbicides.
And so as we were transitioning
to becoming organic,
we along with some of our
neighbors had to figure it out.
How do you live
without chemicals?
For me, it was an
obvious decision.
I live on this farm.
We have grapes
growing about 20 feet
from the front
door of our house,
and raising children there,
it was an obvious thing for me
to not want to have
chemicals in the front yard.
In a conventional farm if
you're applying pesticides
or herbicides, you have to
post these signs with the skull
and crossbones on it that
indicate you've sprayed
or that the chemicals
are there to tell you not
to enter the field
for so many days.
And I'm thinking, OK, I've
got a toddler here as far
away as the window
there, can't cross
the line, because there's
chemicals being sprayed there.
And it just didn't make sense.
So at that early stage,
we along with some
of a handful of
friends that were
growers, and some researchers
from the Cooperative Extension
Service, and other
sources, the universities,
were creating ways to
make organic farming
viable for the types of
products or crops that we grew.
So it's been a long time.
I mean there weren't-- I mean
this is before Whole Foods
Markets, right?
Today, especially
in urban areas,
everyone's aware of Whole
Foods, and Whole Foods kind of
has grown up along with us.
We were an early grower for
Whole Foods back in the day.
We were one of their first
national producers of peaches,
and so as they've
grown, we've grown also.
But they weren't around
our first couple of years.
We had to develop markets.
Our first year of organics all
of our fruit went to baby food.
It was to organic
baby foods, and that's
kind of what got us
through, over the hump,
I would say, from conventional
farming to organics.
It's been a long haul,
and I think at this point,
we think we know
what we're doing now.
JASON CRANE: Yeah,
I guess the skull
and crossbones right
by your front door
isn't going to
really attract anyone
but maybe pirates to
come visit you, so--
MARCY MASUMOTO: Pretty scary
thing when you think about it.
JASON CRANE: So while we're
talking about the not using
chemicals, I was reading that
you guys use pheromones as part
of your abatement to
insects on the farm.
Can we talk a
little bit about how
pheromones play into
the organic mix?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Yeah, pheromones
are kind of a mysterious thing.
And when we started
applying pheromones,
it was our education to our
kids about sex education.
So pheromones are the
scent of the insects that
would thrive, for example,
in a peach orchard,
so there's a couple different
insects that damage peaches.
And you chemically
create the scent
that's applied to a
little plastic strip
that we hang in the tree.
Every couple months you
hang them in the trees,
and what that does
is it emits the scent
so that the male
moth is confused.
It's the scent of the female.
He is attracted to
this, so he never
actually finds the real female.
So mating doesn't occur,
so eggs aren't laid,
so worms don't grow, and
you have clean fruit.
So it's kind of an
interesting cycle.
But actually a place where
technology has really
played a major role
on the family farm.
JASON CRANE: Yeah,
that's super interesting
breaking the livestock
cycle versus trying
to kill individual--
MARCY MASUMOTO: Yeah, if you
wait till you see the worm,
it's too late.
Because you've got lots
of worms everywhere,
so you want to prevent
that from even happening.
JASON CRANE: One of the
lines at the beginning
of a chapter in there from
you was, "Start with great,
and end with great."
Can you talk a little bit
about what that means to you?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Oh, sure.
I'd be delighted.
Say you're going to want
to make a peach pie.
Of course, I think in most
of your minds, you'll say,
I want to make a
really good peach pie.
Well, if you want to
make a good peach pie,
you've got to start
with a good peach
and good primary ingredients.
And with any dish
and any recipe,
I mean why would you want
to start with mediocre?
If you start with
mediocre, then you're
going to be adding
sugar, and salt, and all
these other things to give
it flavor, which in the end,
doesn't really end up with
a better-tasting dish.
It ends up with something
that looks like peach
but may not taste like peach.
So the idea that
start with great,
if you have access
to great food.
Here in California
we're so lucky, so
lucky to have access to so many
different types of produce.
And so why not?
We really don't have
any excuse to not
start with good,
fresh ingredients.
JASON CRANE: Awesome.
Can you talk to me a
little bit about what
your responsibilities
are on the farm?
And how you guys
are a family farm,
and I'm sure everyone has their
own responsibilities out there
to make sure it runs.
Could you talk a little
bit about what you do?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
I'd be happy to.
I have two roles
on the family farm.
One is to make sure the farm
is viable year after year
after year after year, which
means that I actually work off
the farm as well as on the farm.
So I am really lucky
that the job that I have.
I'm involved with
the education world,
so I work full-time
during the academic year,
and during the
summertime I only have
to work limited schedule so that
I have time to work on the farm
when we have the most
work going on on the farm.
Now that doesn't limit my
responsibilities year-round.
As an owner and a
business person,
we're involved with management
and financial decisions
year-round, and
part of what I do
is I help select
fruit varieties,
because I'm the cook, right?
So if I want a
peach that's going
to hold up well
in canning, then I
want to be responsible for
helping make that decision.
So peach selection--
during harvest season
I am responsible
for packing fruit.
We do specialty packs
for high-end grocers
and restaurants, and so
actually, my daughter and I
are out there packing
fruit every day
throughout the summer.
That's our job, and we feel
really passionate about that,
because we want the
eaters, the consumers,
to have the best quality fruit.
And the best quality
fruit is something
that's ripe, or
tree-ripened, and not picked
when it was green
or hard as a rock
and may never ripen correctly.
So my biggest job
during the summer
is packing fruit actually.
And testing recipes when I can.
JASON CRANE: Excellent.
So while we're
talking about this,
talk about what it's like
to actually own a farm
and what goes into
that a little bit.
And then what it's like working
with your family all the time
and being out there
on the family farm.
MARCY MASUMOTO: I'm
curious how many of you
work with your relatives.
Not too many.
OK, a few.
It's a little
different feature when
you are working with your
spouse, working with your kids,
or your children are
working with you.
At this phase, my daughter
is learning all the practices
of farming and working
with her dad every day,
day in and day out.
And that's, think about it.
If you're working with
your parents, you know?
Some days are great, and
some days it's still bad.
So the family dynamics, I think
overall, are pretty amazing.
We also have a son.
I don't want to minimize the
fact that Nikiko has a sibling.
Korio is a little
younger than she is.
He's still in college
and hasn't exactly
decided what he wants to do
yet, but he's really happy
just helping at this point.
And our daughter,
Nikiko, is certainly
committed to being the
one responsible to ensure
that the farm goes on.
So working with your family
is a totally different type
of responsibility.
Farming also can happen
every day of the year.
The nice thing about fruit
is that the trees go dormant
during the winter,
and so the work
isn't as intense
during the winter.
I grew up on a
dairy, and for me, we
had to work every day
of the year regardless,
because you still have
to feed the livestock,
or you still have
to milk the animals.
And so when I met Mas, it
was like, oh, what a treat.
You get winters off.
So that allows him
a little more time
to do the paperwork, the
finances, the planning,
and then some
writing on the side.
So owning a farm is more
than just a business, though.
Because we're a
family farm, we don't
have the corporate mentality.
We do take things personally.
We know our workers personally.
We know every corner
of the property
and know which trees are
going to produce a little more
and which ones need
to break this year.
Or which part of the vineyards
need extra fertilizer
or something like that.
Because we're small
enough, we can
have an intimate relationship
with every part of our farm
and understand
what its needs are.
JASON CRANE: Excellent.
Let's talk a little bit about
peaches for a minute here.
That's what we're
here for, right?
So I have a couple questions.
What are the differences between
yellow flesh and white fleshed
peaches?
MARCY MASUMOTO: OK.
I know that somebody
that talked to me
earlier had a penchant
for white peaches.
Happens to be the Masumotos
like yellow flesh peaches
more what I like about
yellow fleshed peaches
is that they have an
acid sweet balance,
that there's a combination,
where white fleshed peach does
not have the acid.
So it's the sweet.
You have only the sweet flavor.
Depending on the
variety, the textures
might be a little different,
but the primary difference
between the yellow fruit
and the white fruit
is that acid content
in the yellow.
JASON CRANE: Interesting.
Can you tell me about
some of the varietals
that you grow on the farm?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
We happen to grow a
lot of older varieties.
Today if you go to the
market, you probably
noticed that in most
markets, they're
only identified as
yellow or white,
and little do most people
know that, for example,
the yellow fruit,
there are probably
50 different varieties
of yellow fleshed fruit.
And the variety
will dictate when
it's available, when it's ripe.
We have seven different
varieties of peaches,
so our first variety is
called the Spring Lady,
and that will be harvested
mid- to end of May.
And then our last variety is
the Alberta, which comes usually
around the 1st of
August, and we've
got several
varieties in between.
So some of the varieties that
we have-- maybe some of you
have heard of the
Suncrest peach.
That's an older variety that
my husband first wrote about
in his book, "Epitaph for a
Peach," but it's a very tangy,
great-tasting,
out-of-hand-eating peach.
It's great for a salad or
great for something fresh.
Doesn't hold up well at all if
you're trying to cook with it.
It actually just falls apart,
whereas the Alberta peach,
for example, which is another
older heirloom type variety,
is great under heat.
When you add heat, it
just gets nice and firm,
and maintains its
shape and its texture,
and is great for pies or
something, or even canning.
So you want to know
more about varieties?
I'm trying to--
JASON CRANE: I think we'd all
be a little bit more interested.
MARCY MASUMOTO: I think
I'm jumping around
here a little bit.
But let's see, so we have-- I
should look at the Magnificent
Seven, we call them.
It would be a good test to
me just to name them all off.
We have Spring Lady.
We have Gold Dust, which is
another older variety that's
very tender.
Almost looks like a
very large apricot.
If you think of an
apricot and how smooth
the skin is compared
to some peaches.
So there's Gold Dust.
We have a June Crest.
We have the Suncrest.
We have a Flavorcrest, so you
can hear the three, the crests.
They're all somewhat
related, but they're
kind of mid-season fruit.
And then the Alberta.
Did I miss one?
Pretty close,
that's about seven.
JASON CRANE: So in
the book, you talk
about names of
old friends, and I
think we talked a little bit
about this with the heirloom
varieties, but talk a
little bit about what
heirloom varieties
mean for peaches.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Well, I
think what a lot of consumers
don't realize is that
as the years go on,
the growers and the nurserymen
are creating new varieties all
the time.
And what most often is
found in the marketplace
are newer varieties,
which are designed
to be very firm so that they
hold up in refrigeration
and shipping, and lipstick
red color on the outside.
Well, some of the older
varieties of peaches
aren't that red.
The Alberta, for
example, is very
yellow-looking on the outside.
And there's nothing
wrong with this fruit.
Part of our goal with growing
older varieties of fruit
is one, they all
have a unique flavor,
and if you lined up several
varieties next to each other,
you'd really enjoy the nuances.
And some are more
buttery flavor,
and some are tangier even
if they're perfectly ripe.
And what we love is to share
with our consumers, our eaters,
of all ages, these
older varieties
so that people have a palate for
what the different flavors are.
I think a lot of
our younger kids
and younger eaters
think that peaches
are supposed to be
hard and crunchy.
Well, traditionally,
no, that's not the case.
When a peach is
ripe, it's actually
relatively soft and sweet.
And the idea of a
crunchy peach, for me,
is just like fingers
on a chalkboard.
But as young people
learn to eat those,
that's what they're aware of.
And so part of our
passion is to educate
people about the nuances with
peaches and the varieties.
JASON CRANE: Awesome.
I'm learning things
from you today
already, so you're
passing it on already.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Oh, good.
JASON CRANE: This is
probably a quick one,
but cling and freestone.
Can you talk a little
bit about the differences
in those peaches?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
Yeah.
So basically what
we're talking about
is the pit, the seed in
the middle of the peach,
and how readily it releases
from the flesh of the fruit.
So there are some fruit
that if you cut around it,
and you attempted to open it
will just very easily come
apart, and the
pit just pops out.
That's a freestone peach.
The stone falls out freely.
Right?
So as opposed to
what a cling is,
the cling is the fruit
adheres to that pit.
If you do any cooking, and
you know a mango, for example.
You know what that's
like, that the fruit just
sticks to that seed
inside the mango.
That's what a cling
peach is like.
You have to cut it off.
It will never just
slip right off, so.
Some dishes lend themselves
better to one type than others.
If you like to work hard, then
you're going to cut it off,
and you'll use a cling.
If you're eating it free of
hand, you can eat a cling.
If you're trying to make
nice, beautiful little slices
with the red inside portion
that is next to the fruit,
then you probably
want a freestone
so that it opens easily, so.
JASON CRANE: Excellent.
Thank you.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Part of
the science of peaches.
JASON CRANE: We were talking
about the different seasons
of your peaches.
Can you talk a little bit about
the difference between early-,
mid-, and late peaches?
Is it just the
peach that we get,
or is there something
we should know
about eating any peach
throughout the season?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Well,
I think in California--
because we're in
California, we're
going to talk about
California fruit.
So typically the season
for peaches in California
is May through September.
So the earlier
fruit is not going
to have as much time to
mature and develop sugars.
So it typically earlier
fruit are not quite as sweet
or as sugary as the mid-season
or later season fruit.
And again, it just
depends on the variety
in terms of the
sweet tart ratio,
and or what other particular
characteristics the fruit
might have.
It's like if you had
a chardonnay wine,
but six different
versions of chardonnay,
you're still going to have
a spectrum of some sweeter
and some is more drier flavor.
So similar with fruit.
JASON CRANE: OK.
Well, that's kind of a little
segue into something else we
were going to talk about--
the regionality of peaches.
Can you talk a little bit
about not just the California,
but peaches other places, and
a little bit about the climates
and microclimates
and the terroir
that does add these different
flavors to the peaches.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Sure.
Well, I have to say, I've been
a Californian all my life.
So there might be
people in the audience
or viewers that
are from Georgia,
or Michigan, or Pennsylvania, or
other states that grow peaches,
and I can't speak
to those peaches.
But I will tell you that
the soil and the climate
will make a difference as to
one, what kind of varieties
will grow well there, and two,
what the flavor is going to be.
Even on our farm,
on our 80 acres,
if we plant the same
variety on one end of the 80
acres versus the other end,
if the soil type is different,
the flavors of the peaches
will be somewhat different.
And it'll also
depend on fertilizers
and other cultural practices.
But peaches are one
of those fruit that
are very adaptable
to the environment.
So what's beautiful about the
Central Valley, where we live,
is it's very hot, dry climate.
Peaches love hot, dry climate.
Now if you're in Georgia, it's
hot, but it's not always dry.
So it'd probably would be other
varieties that grow better
in that environment
than here in California.
JASON CRANE: Interesting.
You just-- part of what I
see at the grocery store
is the same thing you
were talking about,
where even doesn't
matter what store
you go into unless you go to
an actual farmer's market,
you're going to see
white and yellow peach
and not really
realize that there
are as many varieties
of them as there are.
Can you talk a little bit
about ripeness in a peach?
What are we looking for when
we're looking for ripeness?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Ripeness?
Well, first off,
the first question
that I ask when I'm even trying
to determine the ripeness I
want is, what am I
going to do with it?
So if I'm wanting
to make a sauce,
if I'm wanting to make
jam, I want really what
we call a gusher.
I want a fruit that
is so ready to go
that when you bite
into it, the juice just
squirts out of your mouth.
You don't always find that
in the grocery store though.
So again, this is where if
you a grower or have somebody
at a farmer's market that can
give you tree-ripened fruit,
and then if you want to
leave it out for a while,
then it'll even be riper.
If you want something
that's going to be crunchy,
if you want that
tartness in your salad,
you might want a greener fruit.
So what I look for in ripeness
is two things-- how it feels
and what we call the
background color.
So the feel of the
fruit is critical.
Remember those old
commercials about,
I think there was a
brand of toilet paper
where they're talking about how
it feels, how soft it feels?
And in a way, if you're
looking for the right fruit,
you do need to gingerly
feel that fruit
with your fingertips, with just
the pads of your fingertips.
Now if as you're squeezing
that fruit gently,
if your fingertips
sink into that fruit,
you know that that is ripe, and
you'd better take that one home
with you, because you just left
your fingerprints on it too.
And probably the next person
isn't going to want it,
but that's the fruit that I love
that is really, really soft.
So the ripeness-- if it
feels hard to the touch,
I mean hard like a
baseball, leave it.
It may never get ripe.
But the second thing
that you'd look for
is what we call the
background color.
So if you're looking at
the stem end of your fruit,
of course the stem,
there is no stem.
It's not like an apple.
An apple, the stem's
always in the apple.
But when you pick a peach,
the stem remains on the tree.
But if you're looking
at the stem end,
the color around
that end is going
to give you a really
good indicator
of how ripe that speech is.
If there are green tinges
to that, it's green.
It's not quite ripe.
What I look for is a golden
yellow, kind of that color.
It looks like some
of these chairs here,
not the green ones, but
the golden ones here.
You'd want to look for that
background color for ripeness.
If it's yellow, kind
of a neutral yellow,
it'll probably ripen
on your counter.
Refrigeration is not
good for peaches.
It's like tomatoes.
One, it'll stop the ripening,
and maybe that's what you want.
But if they've been
refrigerated too long,
they're going to become mushy
and mealy and dehydrated.
The best peaches are those
that are left on the counter
and can ripen on
your window sill.
JASON CRANE: As
a little segue, I
was going to ask you what
we should know about storing
and ripening peaches,
and maybe not just
about what we as consumers
do, but what other producers
do when they don't actually
ripen fruit on the tree.
MARCY MASUMOTO: Yeah.
Well, traditionally peaches
are always hand-picked.
It's one of the products
that's not machine-picked yet
at this point in time.
They're hand-picked.
Conventionally, if you're
talking big growers
and oftentimes, they're
picked very green.
They're dumped into big bins.
They go to the packing house.
They roll.
They're dumped out.
They roll down
the conveyor belts
and are sorted and
sized, all mechanically,
and boxed into double or triple
layer boxes, refrigerated, held
under refrigeration for
who knows how long really?
Because in California,
our produce
is shipped all
across the country.
Well, the longer it's in
refrigeration, the more likely
it's going to dehydrate,
and the more likely
it will never ripen if it's been
under long-term refrigeration.
The riper the fruit is, of
course, the more gingerly you
need to handle it.
So for the specialty-packed
fruit that we do, for example,
we pick them by hand,
put them in a box that
are at most double layer
high so that they're not
laying on top of each other
and pressuring each other.
We hand-pick that
peach out of the what
we call the picked box, examine
it for flaws or blemishes,
and place it single layer into
a box that's got dividers in it
so that they're
not rolling around,
and that goes straight
to our buyers,
and they're usually in the
marketplace the next day
or the day after.
So because that they're
not refrigerated long,
they might be cooled
down to kind of slow down
the ripening process, but if
they're already tree-ripened,
you want people to get those
in their hands right away.
JASON CRANE: Yeah, that's great.
So then when we get home, either
storing them on the counter
if they're not quite ripe,
or if they really are,
just go at them and eat
them right away, right?
MARCY MASUMOTO:
Well, the best thing
is if they're ripe, eat
them, use them right away.
Now if you can't, and you want
to slow down the ripening,
because they're there
especially ripe,
put them in the refrigerator,
but get them out
of the refrigerator soon.
Don't leave them in
there for a week or so.
You want to use their peaches
when they're at their peak.
So the less time in
refrigeration, the better.
JASON CRANE: I was
reading through the book,
and it talked about
the chill hours.
And can you explain a little bit
what that means to the peaches?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Yeah.
We like to think of
chill hours, which
is during the dormancy
season during the winter.
So different
varieties of peaches
actually require so many
hours of temperatures
below 45 degrees,
around 800 hours
over the winter from
October to February or so,
which allows the tree
to really get some rest.
What we like to call it
is a good solid sleep.
When you've been working
hard a long stretch,
if you don't get a good
solid sleep sooner or later,
you're going to wake up
grumpy, and you might not
be as productive as
you'd like to be.
So with our peaches, they really
need a nice solid winter rest,
to sleep, cold temperatures.
This winter we had
kind of a warm winter,
so hopefully the season
will be good this year.
Typically if they've got
a good solid 800 hours
of cold temperatures,
the flavors
tend to be better
during the year.
So we'll see.
It's been so dry also that we've
noticed that the soils are just
sucking up the moisture now.
We've watered more
frequently than we have ever
in our last 30 years,
and just with the drought
and the dryness.
Those trees are just inhaling
the water that they get.
JASON CRANE: So the last
chapter in your book
you were talking
about preservation.
You want to talk a little bit
about what goes into that,
or why you see the value
of preserving foods?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Right.
One of the things while we
were working on this cookbook
was we basically were asked to
get the book done in 18 months.
And we asked our publishers to
stretch it over to two years
so that we would
have two full harvest
seasons to test recipes.
And why is that important?
It was important to us, because
during the winter months, when
we went to the grocery
store and bought produce
that came from South
America, because that was
the only place that produce was
being harvested at that time,
but by the time they
got to our market,
and by the time I got them
home, at least four out of five,
I was throwing away.
They were mealy,
they were brown.
They looked fine on the
outside, but you cut into them,
and you really did
not want to eat them.
So that's part of the backstory.
The other part is I grew
up on a farm myself.
My folks were from the Midwest
and god Depression-era folks,
and learned how to preserve
all types of foods.
And so at an early age,
I learned how to can,
and I brought some
examples here today
if anybody wants to take a look.
So some of the things that you
can do with peaches, canning.
This is probably a pretty
typical idea of jarred.
I guess people today
are calling them
jarred, but a half
type of peach.
Also have done and included
recipes for pickled peaches,
which are great-- oops, I'm
sorry-- a great accompaniment.
But these are whole peaches
that have some spices in them.
But during the wintertime,
oh, it's so lovely.
Thanksgiving, have turkey with
a pickled peach next to it,
and it just reminds
you of summertime,
and it's just so delightful.
Also then, I've
got some other kind
of California-style recipes.
There's a peach salsa, which
a peach and tomato salsa,
which is also a treat.
And then I've got
some chutney, which
is a spiced kind of chopped
peach with raisins in it.
I include gold-- I
include dark raisins,
because that's what we grow.
So that's a lot of fun.
But what we wanted to encourage
people through the cookbook
is again, if you have
access to good fruit,
then why not do
something with it
so you can enjoy it year-round?
So we've also included how
to dehydrate your peaches
if you want to do that, or
how to freeze the peaches.
It's so easy.
It's really easy, and if
you've never canned before,
do not be afraid of canning.
It's a pretty easy process.
If I can do it,
anybody can do it.
JASON CRANE: Awesome.
Thanks for that.
Is there anyone who
has any questions
out here today for us?
AUDIENCE: So when peach
season comes around,
I always try to pay attention at
Berkeley Bowl for the Masumoto
peaches, but I'm
wondering, do you
have any kind of email
notification that you send out?
Or do you ship directly now?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Oh,
that's a good question.
So she was asking, she shops
at Berkeley Bowl, which
happens to be one of our really
terrific long-time markets
that we've worked with,
and we do ship directly
to Berkeley Bowl.
And those peaches are the
ones that I and my daughter
have hand-packed, so you're
pretty lucky to get some.
But yeah, if you want to
log on to our website,
we do have a newsletter,
and my daughter also
tweets when the fruit's
going to be delivered up here
in the East Bay.
And so you can
find out then when
it's arriving to Berkeley
Bowl or a few other places.
And if you're someplace
else, because we're
too small to be shipping
things by the huge lots,
but we're too big to know where
all of our fruit is going.
So if you happen to be
at some other market,
and you see the
Masumoto fruit and let
us know that we can tweet it
out to other folks too that,
oh, it showed up over at
this market in this city.
JASON CRANE: My last
question for you
is how was your
day here at Google?
Tell me a little
bit about what it
was like for you seeing
our cafe in action
and how our chefs
cooked up peaches
to your recipes and
their own recipes,
and just what was your day like?
MARCY MASUMOTO: Oh,
I was so delighted.
From the moment I walked
in the door today,
it was just really a
delightful day, from the chefs
and the staff in the cafe, and
what they did was beautiful.
They made some recipes
directly from the book.
They also took some
and tweaked them,
which is exactly
what a recipe is.
It's like a guideline, right?
So take an idea,
and then go with it.
And the fact that
here we are in April,
and they found some
peaches and did
some pretty remarkable
things with those.
They also used some
of our dried peaches,
and that was a real treat.
But it's totally amazing to
me what happens here at Google
and how lucky all of you are.
The care that goes into
the selection of the food,
and the preparation, and I know
Bon Appetit Management Company
helps oversee the food
service, and their commitment
to high-quality
food, because it's
nourishing the body,
the soul, the mind.
It's not just food.
I think that food is a special
thing, because you take it
in to your body, and what could
be more personal than that?
And the fact that
a company this size
cares so much about
their employees
to provide not only some
food, but great food,
and it was cooked to perfection.
I was so mind-boggled.
It's really wonderful.
What a great opportunity.
JASON CRANE: Well, awesome.
It was really great having
you out here today, Marcy.
Pleasure to meet you.
I look forward to hunting
my farmer's markets
and wherever I can to find
your peaches this summer.
And have a great rest
of your, and really,
thanks for coming
out here today.
MARCY MASUMOTO: My
pleasure to be here.
Thank you so much.